who are you
a friend
is one thing I do Nelson and that is you
are here for a reason there you go
friend
very cool costume thanks my mom made it
for me
I just wish you could all see the Earth
the way that I see
because when you really look at it
what's CS stand for it's not an ass
or my world it means hope
dreams Lift us up and transform us into
something better and on my soul I'll
never stop fighting I believe in second
chances I believe in Redemption but
mostly
I believe in my friends I'm proud of you
Jonathan you put the world above
yourself that's what a hero does any
more at home like you uh not really no
one ever dreams about the problem
problem with every life
even the extraordinary ones
you will give the people of love an
ideal to strive towards
they'll rest behind you that will
stumble
time they will join you in the sun
he may have come from another world
but he will always belong to ours
foreign